[Música]
así que trabajo en la seguridad
desde muy joven casi que desde que las
ramas criaban pelo
y
y la seguridad es un entorno masculino
en aquella época era la única mujer
así que tuve que mimetizarme con el
entorno masculino
y aprender a trabajar
con la regla del juego' que existían en
ese campo
aprender a trabajar en equipo con
hombres de centroamérica de centro
europa del norte de europa de norte
américa de españa'
con las mismas reglas de juego
hasta que un día
el director de europa
me dijo
tener un hijo
con 40 años
es un lujo que un directivo de tu nivel
no se puede permitir
creo que algunas se pueden poner en mi
lugar y ese fue el momento en el que
pensé
si no me valoras no me mereces
y esa reflexión me dio el impulso para
crear mi propia empresa
para ser empresaria
y cuando di ese paso
ese fue el momento en que yo descubrí mi
esencia femenina
ese fue el momento en el que deje de
mimetizarme
y empezar a ser yo misma
porque somos diferentes hay un
metabolismo basal que es distinto
los hombres tienen músculos una masa
muscular de tipo 2 las mujeres de tipo 1
los hombres tienen un 10% menos de grasa
que nosotras
los hombres tienen un metabolismo basal
que les hace quemar energía
potencia rapidez
así que cuando estábamos en las cavernas
qué hacían los hombres la supervivencia
de la especie que hacían ir a cazar
claro claro ir a cazar y entonces cuando
cazaban ahí es que mira pepe me cae
fatal es que me cae fatal pero es que
pepe tiene un ojo que allí donde pone el
ojo pone la flecha
es que necesito app
pero es que blas
mira blas es un cretino y un prepotente
que no hay quien pueda con él pero que
estratega
matemático
es que necesito blas así que desde el
principio de los tiempos el hombre por
supervivencia aprendió a trabajar en
equipo
y se iban a cazar juntos claro está los
mamuts los enormes mamuts porque no
podía uno solo ir a cazar un mamut
tenían que ir en equipo o sino no
sobrevivir y qué pasaba con nosotras
donde estábamos las mujeres mientras
ellos trabajaban en equipo nosotras
estábamos en el interior de la cueva
dentro de la caverna y teníamos dos
oficios 21
las cuidadoras
preparamos ungüentos cataplasmas
cuidamos de los ancianos de los niños de
los enfermos y no en balde si miráis las
estadísticas hoy debe de ser muy fuerte
el asunto porque hoy más del 70% de las
mujeres de los estudiantes de medicina
son mujeres está ahí es una realidad
pero a nivel mundial
hay ahí una potencia nuestra esencia de
cuidadoras y las otras donde estaban las
otras mujeres pues las otras como no
sólo de carne vive la especie las otras
mujeres eran recolectoras así que
teníamos que salir de la cueva dentro de
la cueva vamos muy amigas hay mar y qué
bonito pelo tienes estás preciosa
guapísima pero por qué pero al que niños
tan hermosos íntimas amigas en el
interior de la hueva hasta que
llegábamos a la puerta de la cueva y
cuando llegábamos a la puerta de la
cueva mari y puri tenían que salir a
recolectar y entonces mar y decía ajá
que yo ayer vi un árbol que tenía diez
manzanas
pour y tiene cinco hijos y yo tengo
otros cinco
y hasta aquí llegamos porque somos
competencia
así que poor y tú te vas por tu lado y
yo me voy por el mío porque son tus
hijos o los míos
y está claro verdad la supervivencia de
la especie es lo primero así que las
mujeres
desde entonces lo vemos lo vemos hoy en
día esa que se compra una camisa
estupenda pero que es incapaz de decirle
a la amiga dónde se la compró y qué es
una tienda que está en liquidación
o esa que pero que te has hecho en la
cara nada
no me he hecho nada
todavía existe esto
es más sube el nivel cuántas
asociaciones de mujeres conocéis que
luchamos por lo mismo cuántas yo conozco
veo por allí gesto de uf yo conozco a sí
y cada vez hay más y cada vez se crean
más y más y más y más asociaciones de
mujeres que hacen exactamente lo mismo y
están luchando por la paridad
exactamente igual que las demás entrando
en competencia a las unas con las otras
en lugar de crear redes cuando creó
redes donde están los pulgares hacia
arriba triunfamos todos
y entonces un buen día en la caverna
volvamos otra vez a la prehistoria un
buen día en las cavernas
los mamuts se cargaron a los hombres
nos quedamos sin cazadores ojo
o la tribu enemiga en cualquiera de
ambas cosas
volvemos al interior a la web ahí están
las cuidadoras y las recolectoras allí
que hacemos
si buscáis a lo largo ya lo ancho
de la historia y del planeta veréis que
se habla de ellas
de las míticas increíbles temidas
tremendamente temidas mujeres amazonas
las mujeres guerreras quienes son estas
mujeres pues fueron esas del interior de
la caverna que evolucionaron porque no
les quedó más remedio porque era una
cuestión de supervivencia que tuvieron
que dejar de ser cuidadoras y
recolectoras para aprender a trabajar en
equipo
tuvieron que evolucionar porque sí no
no sobreviví a la especie y empezaron a
crear redes
la supervivencia obligó a estas amazonas
a trabajar juntas haciéndose fuertes en
eso los hombres descubrieron cuando
cazaban
haciéndose fuerte en lo que nos une y no
es lo que nos diferencia por eso es la
clave del trabajo en equipo ser fuertes
es lo que nos une
tenemos
lo decían antes el presentador siento
70 años y todavía tenemos una asignatura
pendiente trabajar nosotras en equipo
y trabajar en equipo con los hombres
porque la violencia de género tiene dos
víctimas una es la más visible la mujer
pero antes de que se produzca esa
violencia hay otro hombre que está
sufriendo es el que es víctima de sí
mismo queremos acabar con esta violencia
de género tenemos que hacer redes
también con los hombres y aprender a
trabajar en equipo con ellos gracias
[Aplausos]